spread over a sprawling 25,000 square
metres the premium trade fair offers
some 1,000 brands the chance to showcase
their new collections within the context
of Berlin Fashion Week buyers come from
all over the world to order the designs
that will be hanging in stores in the
coming winter
miss Tia Vicki Shabo I really work here
we start every morning at ten and go
from stand to stand looking at every
collection premium offers the best
overview I've seen anywhere in Europe
and it's very international everyone
wants to show their new collection here
because this is where the money is made
Berlin has this image as a place where
people just party or visit shows in the
evening but we can't do that we don't
have time I might manage one show during
the whole week in the arms of a stylist
not the premium premium was founded 12
years ago by Anita timin and her
business partner they wanted to set up a
fair where they got to pick the
exhibiting labels yeah on your phone we
started out with the aim of
revolutionising the trade fair landscape
to make it somewhere that no longer sold
in standard exhibition halls or sold the
labels that booked the largest spaces
what we wanted to do was choose what we
thought was relevant for the market
premium offers exhibitors the choice of
ready-to-use stand systems which are
particularly good for smaller labels and
young designers or larger areas that
exhibitors can design themselves the
rule in trade fairs and shows are the
first in the year so for many designers
it's their first public outing
relatives near I'm feedback about the
products we want to launch reaches us
pretty quickly so it's really important
to show everything early in the season
it means we still have the chance to
rethink and rework things so the earlier
the better on dorvalla isn't where
typhoon thorns off-again school a couple
of days before the show I needed him on
is working flat out when she first
pitched her idea for a curated trade
fair nobody showed any interest so in
2002 she decided to try it out for
herself in Berlin it was a success but
in order to make it more appealing to
buyers she wanted to establish her own
fashion week in the German capital in
2005 she presented her idea to IMG the
organizers of the new york fashion week
and the berlin fashion week was born
it's not traditional a trade fair is not
glamorous and consumers are not involved
we had one chance to put berlin on the
map of europe we had to start everything
from the beginning which meant we had to
go to New York and talk to IMG and
explained to them how important Berlin
is as the geographical center of Europe
and also as an interface between Old
Europe and Eastern Europe well I snitch
still excited to tonight all good all
Europe on the Austin whether she's
supporting emerging talent with the
premium young designers award dreaming
up new trade fair concepts such as seat
or her own magazine for Fashion Week the
mother-of-two takes her responsibility
for Berlin as a fashion capital very
seriously amor de danse indoor
sunglasses in the past German fashion
was very commercial and pretty average
Germany's designers moved to Paris New
York or London you still meet them in
other places but in Berlin we've now
created a place they can all come back
to me that's a look on Conan much has
happened since the first premium showed
70 brands in a disused Berlin subway
tunnel and
3500 visitors in 2007 the trade fair
bought a permanent home in what used to
be the largest parcel distribution
center in Berlin in the next days 60,000
experts from the fashion industry are
expected one census figures show that
the fashion and textile industries
turnover more than the car industry in
Germany if not worldwide very few people
know that because people always
associate fashion with glamour she she
and a couple of bloggers photographers
fact is a lot of jobs are created in the
industry and with a trade fair we can
offer full-time employment all year
round abouts pizza con sele for Anita
Tillman and her staff the post trade
fair phase is also the pre trade fair
phase next week planning for the summer
premium will get underway